(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Few industries
have been as impacted
by the coronavirus as
the grocery business.
When lockdowns began, grocery
stores transformed themselves
physically to respond to safety concerns.
At the same time, demand skyrocketed,
pushing food retails sales to record highs
and in many cases, remaking
entire supply chains.
- I've been in this business
since I was a child.
COVID-19 was something
we've never seen before.
- Everybody has been affected,
and I think the industry will be remade
in the future as a result.
- [Narrator] The pandemic
has triggered a boom
in online shopping.
Instacart, the nation's
biggest independent
grocery delivery service
reported that its order volumes
are up as much as 500% year over year.
- So what happens next?
What will be the lasting
legacy of COVID-19
for the food retail
industry and its workers?
Simply put, how will we
shop in the near future?
- [Narrator] Plastic shields, masks,
social distancing markers.
If you've visited a grocery store any time
in the past few months, you've
almost certainly encountered
these new cosmetic changes.
But what about consumer behavior?
Are we shopping differently?
- There I am.
- [Narrator] To find out,
I spoke with Bill Bishop,
a veteran industry analyst.
- Consumers are, first of all,
going to the store less frequently.
They are rushing through
the shopping experience
more quickly than normal,
browsing is not fashionable.
- During the pandemic
people definitely started
buying different things.
- Kelvin Rodriguez
operates an independent,
family run grocery store,
Billy's Marketplace,
in Ridgewood Queens.
- Number one was paper, paper products.
A lot of non perishables and
they were buying more bulk.
- [Narrator] Before the pandemic,
local independent stores
like Billy's Marketplace
made up only about 11%
of all grocery sales.
Most Americans shop at the
nation's biggest chains
like Walmart, Amazon
Whole Foods, or Kroger.
- The retail grocery
business is a huge business
made up of many competitors
which makes it hyper competitive
and a very low margin business.
- Before the pandemic, grocery
stores in the inner city
I would say were struggling a bit.
Right, there was a lot of competition.
There was a lot of big box
stores coming into New York.
- [Narrator] To cater to the tastes
of his mostly millennial customers,
Rodriguez set up a beer bar
in a coffee shop in the store.
- [Rodriguez] We wanted
to create an experience
and that's where we thought
this industry was headed.
We wanted to create where you could
almost get everything in one.
We know everyone that's
walking in through that door
and we have a relationship
with our customers.
- [Narrator] But with New York
still on partial lockdown,
those offerings are simply not possible
because of safety regulations.
Fortunately, late last year
Rodriguez had the foresight
to jump on the biggest trend
in food retail, e-commerce.
- Usually we don't know
the difference between
an Instacart shopper
and a regular shopper.
- [Narrator] With such low margins,
it's impractical for smaller operations
to create their own delivery services.
Instead, if independent
stores like Billy's
want to sell online,
they have to look to third
party companies like Shopify,
Fresh Direct, or Instacart.
- Previous to pandemic,
it was about one percent,
which you would say one
percent is pretty small.
After the pandemic, it doubled,
it went to two percent.
- [Narrator] Although
a one percent increase
may not sound like much,
in an industry with such low margins,
one percent can be the difference
between being profitable
or simply breaking even.
In a statement to the Wall Street Journal,
Instacart wrote, "We believe
that brick and mortar retailers
"are the backbone of
the future of grocery.
"people want to shop from the
grocers they love and trust
"and have gone to for generations."
Before the pandemic,
online grocery shopping
was a small fraction of
all grocery shopping.
But since then, it has gone mainstream.
- Well, the largest player
in grocery would be Walmart.
- [Narrator] Walmart has
approximately 5,000 US stores,
which can be found 10 miles
from 90% of the US population.
- We've been focused in
this space for a while now
building up our curbside
pickup capabilities
that are in over 3,300 of our
locations as we stand today
and growing each week.
- [Narrator] According to Ward,
although the trend toward online shopping
has existed for a while now,
the coronavirus accelerated its adoption.
- [Ward] We heard that
customers felt more comfortable
if they didn't have to
have a personal exchange.
All of our curbside interactions
now are contactless.
In fact, our customers don't
even wind their window down
and the transaction is
conducted inside the vehicle.
Our associates load the trunk
on the customer's behalf.
- [Narrator] More than
38.6 million Americans
have filed for unemployment since March,
creating a new talent pool
for those expanded operations.
One area of growth has been
in non traditional gig work.
Instacart, for example,
relies on gig workers
to shop for its customers.
But like many industries
that rely on gig workers,
the sustainability of this delivery model
depends heavily on the
worker's compensation
and whether they are
classified as employees.
The long term benefits for
retailers with an online presence
lies in the data they can
collect about their customers.
- If a retailer has your
business online and offline
it gives you a complete
picture of the household
or a much more complete
picture, which is very valuable.
- [Narrator] The growth of
e-commerce has also given rise
to dark stores, the name
of which can be misleading.
Dark stores aren't really
stores in a traditional sense
because they're not open to customers.
They're more like depots that
serve primarily as a location
for pickup or dispersed delivery.
- It's particularly important
because it's a route profitability.
The cost of picking the order,
it's what we call pick and pack,
is substantially less in a dark store.
- [Narrator] Looking
further into the future,
a sign of things to come could be
online only companies like Ocado.
Based in the UK, Ocado
only does home deliveries
from its warehouses.
- Ocado is a stand alone online service
that is generally regarded as
the absolute state of the art.
If a typical supermarket
is 50,000 square feet,
an Ocado unit is 350,000 square feet
and it reached tremendous efficiencies.
- [Narrator] In a statement
to the Wall Street Journal,
Ocado said, "Kroger has
licensed Ocado's technology
"and will be going live
"with its first highly
automated warehouses
"in the not too distant future."
Back in Queens, Rodriguez
remains confident
that once the pandemic passes,
his customers will still
want the neighborhood
in store experience that Billy's offers.
- I'm really tryna get people here.
I feel like if everything goes online,
what kind of experience
are you really gonna have?
You've gotta get out
of the house sometimes,
so its almost to make people feel at home.
That's really what we wanted to do,
make people feel at home at the store.